hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i'm going to be
upgrading
my webcam you are currently looking at
me through
a logitech brio i've had it for a number
of years it has served me
quite well it can be pretty crisp um but
you can also definitely see you know
some lighting issues causing uh always
this kind of stuttery effect on my green
screen i guess we can wave just to
you know show you kind of what the frame
rate situation is and while i am
relatively happy with the logitech brio
not a terrible webcam
i did get a new webcam
from razer this is the keo
pro so this thing has a high performance
adaptive light sensor for superior
imaging in any lighting condition
uncompressed 1080 60 frames per second
for absolute video fidelity
light and fast usb 3.0 to support
uncompressed video quality hdr enabled
for more vibrant colors at 30 frames per
second
flexible mounting options for ideal
webcam placement and a wide angle lens
with adjustable
fov to control how much to capture
for your audience so let's open it i'm
excited
okay okay okay all right what's
happening
i love that my green screen would keys
out
let them raise it green okay
it's time to get seen and be heard
streaming is one of the fastest growing
entertainment platforms in the world
i feel like i should mention that this
was basically designed for streamers
that is worth noting
the razer broadcaster line features
products specially
engineered for streaming cool we have oh
oh oh it's so pretty compared to
wow look at it
my current webcam the logitech brio is
just like it just looks like a webcam
you know it's just like a little flat
sort of this thing
fancy okay this is going to be an
instruction booklet which if i know
myself
i will pretend to read but absorb
absolutely none of um
yes does have a built-in microphone
camera thread mount a power port a
detachable stand a stand thread mount
it is actually pretty cool they note the
amount of different kind of
setup options they've got for you okay
let's take
it out it's so sleek like it just looks
like a real
camera okay also a lot thicker
than i would have expected this this
looks like a lens
again recognizing my logitech brio also
technically has a lens
uh yep got you nice stand here this is
gonna clip on the top of my monitor i
actually don't
really because i don't have so much
space in this apartment don't really
have an ideal setup for any kind of
camera
um so i'm hoping that this can kind of
help with some of those issues as my
lighting setup in this apartment is
absolutely atrocious
my light is to the left um and above me
and half cut off by my monitor
because i just don't have any room okay
we have this is gonna be a lens
cap yeah i am a
very obsessive about using privacy
shields on webcams
big fan if you're using your webcam
remember that privacy ship when you walk
away
um maybe it's me being overly cautious
or maybe it's a comment that this dude
left on reddit
that stuck with me forever because it
was really creepy
so they're here and all that okay we
have
the cables beautiful
usbc gonna slot right in there i also
feel like
yeah we got we got a lot of flexibility
here i don't have flexibility with the
logitech brio to move it left and right
i don't believe um so that's neat the
part of this that is going to suck is
that my cable management is
so specific changing the webcam
can be real pain in the ass however
because of what i'm about to do
i may have to take the logitech brio out
i'm not sure yet but that would mean
that next time i see you i will be
seeing you on the razer keo pro
so stay tuned and before i say anything
else about this
i do want to say this video is not
sponsored however
they have sponsored me previously what
that means is that i am choosing to make
this because
i think it will be interesting content
um because i think it will be
informative
uh but i will be you know 100 genuine in
all opinions here
but i do still want to disclose that
they did pay me to talk about this
product previously
i'm making this video personally because
i want to essentially regardless
if you've ever wanted to see me
completely destroy something
that i was sponsored by uh go look at my
marvel's avengers video
that might be the most negative i've
ever been about a video game on this
channel ever
and they did sponsor me it doesn't
matter wait let me show you what it
looks like without the
filter on first hang on
okay okay so you were wondering what it
looks like without that green static
this is my green screen this is what
this looks like
let's change cameras okay wait wait i
discovered something new
that okay so it has this right but it
also does this
it's going to be a good time oh also
let's
yeah good content
okay everything from this point onward
will be shot on the razer keo
pro so wide
wow you can really see
my living room and my kitchen
because i live in a studio apartment
let's do a side by side
okay let's just have the other one on
one side and then me here and then we'll
see
the difference but right now i feel like
yeah the color is more natural
rate looks great that autofocus is doing
a good job let's check
properties highest fps
okay
dude i feel like that's really good
okay so this is it's pretty common for
me to zoom in
um even with my out my old webcam i
would zoom in
um just because you know my background
is
very busy because my apartment is very
small but i feel like
i i it often would look a lot more
pixelated so let's do the chroma key or
we're probably going to have to
customize it for this oh that's
way better
you can still see it oh i haven't
changed the lighting at all
um wow okay
so i'm gonna wait till uh the razer
updater finishes doing what it's doing
but my first impressions this is all
genuine i didn't do really anything at
all other than just plug in a hit start
record
first impressions are extremely positive
um the downside is i'm now gonna have to
do my makeup better because
you'll be able to see that i'm really
lazy about it
i don't often wear much um
no it's good the frame rate is good it's
all good
okay i'll be right back so while i wait
for the
uh razer app to update i just thought
that i would show you guys
kind of what i was talking about this is
what my setup for streaming looks like
it's very simple
um that's my light not the light's fault
that it's so terrible but like i said
we have a very wide monitor it causes
some problems so this is what my
logitech brio looks like
very standard doesn't have any tilt
function or anything like that if i want
to adjust it i have to do it with the
back
um nothing adjustable on that really at
all this
is my razor but now we can like swivel
we can tilt down uh that's definitely
not supposed to be done one-handed but
you get the idea
um it's certainly a lot bigger i'm not
going to tell you it doesn't stand out
a lot more uh but i do think it's very
cool looking it's
it's pretty sleek um and like i said you
know just even
from the hardware way more functionality
i haven't even
really dug into the software yet so yeah
that's what my setup looks like and uh
that's what it looks like on top of my
pc here
okay so here's how things look actually
in the app
this is gonna open up just a regular old
webcam settings probably pretty similar
range
to what i'm used to
um cool with it a little bit more
saturation that's nice actually
i did feel like the default setting i
was looking pretty
flushed out i would like some less
sharpness
white balance seems good low-light
compensation i wonder what it'll change
that's the thing about this camera
that's supposed to be like exceptionally
good from what i've read
is that it's it's really good uh oh
camera um for low light settings so i
guess if i turn
this light off
i think that does still look better than
my old camera for sure when the lights
were off obviously nothing i can do
about the shadows from the lights that
are directly above me
but it's still a clean image um i am
gonna say though
just even from the way that i'm moving
right now i feel like
i wanted to say the autofocus is a
little bit wonky it's still really good
um but we are seeing it kind of jump in
and out more frequently than i'm used to
oh so here we can change fov
i'm interested to see what that looks
like
that's narrow
it's gone all fisheye
whoa i feel like for someone who has a
an apartment yeah needs more space than
mine this
definitely could look really cool um and
it's for sure new for me
but we're gonna keep it narrow yeah that
autofocus i think maybe will turn off
and then just manually find it probably
is what we'll do
uh hdr on or off
that is off
that is on i think i actually maybe like
it better without hdl
it just looks softer
yeah i think i do that's interesting um
of course
everyone's setups kind of makes these
things apply differently like based on
what you have
in your setup you're going to like uh
different kinds of things this is
generally what i'll do for playing a
video game
about that i think this looks so much
crisper
it looks way better the main thing that
gets me is definitely
the lack of the green screen stutter in
the background
um i was so sure that what i had to do
to fix that was to get another light
uh i know some people stick lights on
the back of their chairs to kind of try
and prevent this thing
um this kind of thing and i've also had
a problem where in a lot of my videos
the cyberpuncture because it's yellow
which is you know obviously
not too far off green would also get
keyed out
um on the logitech brio because it
couldn't differentiate those two colors
well enough whereas right now we got a
solid yellow
and a whole lot of black so hey
this is awesome um yeah it looks great
to me
i guess we'll keep using it i'll give
you guys any updates if i have any but
for now i'm very happy with it huge
thanks to razer to sending me one
um of course again i do want to be super
explicit that while this is not a
sponsored video
nothing in here they don't even know i'm
making this video i'm choosing to
because i figured it would be
informative um
and you know genuine reactions are
always interesting to watch
uh but they did sponsor me previously
for a stream to talk about this
particular webcam obviously i said yes
because i was interested in the webcam
but i do want to be just super explicit
about that so yeah this is the razer
keyo pro
and it's going to be my go to webcam
from now on so if you've ever wondered
what i use to stream
the answer was logitech brio and is now
razer keo
pro it is sharp i'm going to have to do
my makeup better that's the one downside
though otherwise i guess the kind of
cons that we touched on here are
i'm not a huge fan of the hdr and i
think the auto focus is a bit off i felt
like it was just kind of
grabbing uh where it shouldn't have been
so i'm probably gonna need to manual
focus with this one
um but otherwise
looks great alright i hope you guys
enjoyed this video let me know if you
have any more questions i will see you
guys next time